so hello everyone my name is andre
um i'm going to be talking about data
loss and since i don't have
that much time only 25 minutes or so i'm
going to jump straight into this because
the
my description of who i am what i do is
on the website and
for the being interested anyway uh so
when we talk about
uh data loss we uh there's quite a few
postpartums online of large companies
describing how they how they lost a lot
of data in some incidents
and these often involve databases and
environments so things like oh we
thought we were
doing something in our development or
staging environment and we're dropping a
few things and we are actually connected
to a production database and and dropped
a whole bunch of data
or you want to delete a subset of your
data in a in a sql database
but you forget the where clause instead
of deleting a subset you actually delete
the whole thing or my favorite
you have some sort of a
some sort of a bad crash and um
instead of instead of using your backups
you are not using a backup
user you don't have any or you have
backups but you haven't really exercised
the whole
uh scenario of using the backup so this
for example what happened with gitlab
they had like five
uh backup systems but they also failed
on the on the night that they
actually crashed
what i want to talk about instead is
losing data
without actually noticing it this
is uh for data pipelines and
data engineering systems where
everything is running smoothly there are
no errors there might not even be any
warnings and
there might not even be any nulls in
your data but you're actually losing
data at the
uh whilst these are running and these
are all stories
from uh my actual work the the examples
that i'm gonna be showing are gonna be a
little bit contrived
but the sort of the issues at hand are
gonna be uh drawn from experience
uh the underlying uh the underlying
theme of this whole thing
is um how a system
this could be like a parser this could
be a database this could be a data
processing engine
how does it handle incorrect inputs
so you can think of it like let's say
there's an in function in python which
converts
a a string which uh which is
a string representation of a number into
an actual number
and um so so interval one two three is
going to give you 123.
so uh then the question is what happens
if you give it something that is not a
number let's say you give it a string of
hello what is the name of hello so
there's basically three things that you
can do if you implement a function like
this
either you can fail which is basically
you raise an exception
you uh you exit the process you
burn whatever whatever it is in your
environment
or you can return null which is
basically saying hey i can't parse hello
as an
as a number but let me let me give you a
nun
or nil or no whatever the the sentinel
value for
null is in your system just as a sort of
a hey i don't want to crash
i'm just going to give you a num and the
third option my favorite
is to parse it incorrectly so you might
have
this hello and the system might be like
oh that sounds like a seven so i'm just
going to give you seven
as a as a result of interval and
these things actually happen and we're
going to go through a few of these
so here is here is an example so
here i'm creating a csv from scratch
i'm emitting imports and stuff like that
but
just so you know all the code and a
lot more description that i'm giving you
here is going to be
online on my blog i'm going to link to
it at the at the very end and they're
going to be
even more examples so no need to sort of
take any pictures or
or copy anything so here
i'm creating a csv with some names and
some dates
and uh whatever that may be like last
birthday or something like that i
i did prepare this a few months ago so
this is still 2019.
um and uh you may notice that some of
these dates don't actually exist so last
year wasn't a leap year so
well this wouldn't be valid even in a
leap year but 29th of
uh february was not a was not a thing
and april only has 30 days so this is
not a thing either
here i'm using apache spark for those
who don't know it's
the most well it was the most active
apache project as of last year
and probably still is it's one of the
most used data data processing engines
it's it has a concept of
data frames like pandas but also has a
sql interface like databases
and it's it's very performant and it's
used for large scale data processing
and manipulation and analysis
uh and in this case i'm telling you hey
i have a csv it has a header and i
wanted to
want you to to infer the schema so
here we can sort of exercise the uh the
three options that we have so
uh so i'm telling you
it's a uh here here's a date and it can
infer and it might say okay so this
looks like a date but these days are not
valid so i'm just going to leave it as a
string
or it can say oh it looks like a date
but it's not actually valid
so for those who are that are invalid
i'm just going to place nulls
or it could recognize as dates
and then upon parsing them you might
just fail with an exception saying oh
hey this is not a validity i'm just
going to give you a second to think
about
what which of these approaches
spark might take
the answer is none of them it actually
chooses something completely different
it actually chooses to overflow these
dates so
if you're familiar with the the concept
of overflows
so uh in
in progress and variables can be can be
said to be integers that contain only
values let's say from
minus 128 to 127 so if if you give it
200 it's going to overflow
and give you some sort of a some small
negative number
and this is what's happening here so
we've got 30th of february
which is uh if you sort of
i just sort of think about it like how
how how this could happen because i've
never i had never seen this in my life
before i
i saw this in a real life production
system it's actually two days after the
28th of
february so it's going to be 2nd of
march and 29th of february is going to
be 1st of march and 31st of
april is going to be first of may
so the issue with this apart from it
being completely wrong
is that these are valid dates
but they don't conform to these dates so
if you have a system like
great expectations that were described
at length today's workshop
and you check for nulls and stuff like
that these are not gonna get flagged up
you're just going to have
completely invalid dates without any
errors without any way of detecting that
they're
uh that their problems with them you
might also be asking like how could i
get
30th of february in my data there are
plenty of ways invalid dates can get in
your data sets
just look at like leap year issues and
stuff like that
there's plenty of ways that or people
might confuse days and months and
and this could happen
or you might be thinking hey i don't
care about that date column it's just
it's just if there's a problem with it
it's going to be isolated to that column
and everything else is going to be all
right and if i've got like an invoice
data set i'm only going to be interested
in the client id the invoice id
and the amount for example and i want to
do some reporting on that
here is an example of how that might
work
i've got a again i've got a csv a very
simple one three columns
a bunch of integers you might notice
here this is not an integer it's a
floating point
but it looks sort of inner jewelry it's
it's
it it could be it could be an integer if
you omitted the point zero but it
technically it is a floating point
and in my um in my scheme i'm going to
define it all as integers
this is what spark lets you do you can
define the schema it's actually a
good thing for you because then you can
sort of uh
impose some sort of a structure on your
data set and make sure that what you're
getting
is not something that's inferred but
that's actually what you what you give
it
so i'm going to give it a schema and
tell it that there's a header and and
let it read
and this is something that burned us
really badly because then
what happened was that it encountered
the 15.0 and it wasn't an integer so it
placed a null
but given that the data point didn't
conform to the schema
it actually nullified the whole row
which is something that we did not
expect at all and
we only we only discovered this when we
started getting like
columns that should never ever ever be
now like ids of some events and stuff
like that
and there were just suddenly so many
nulls in our data set just because some
data started suddenly coming in as an
um uh as a different data type which
happens uh in live production systems
all the time
uh the good news is that the previous
and the current
so the so this example and the date
overflow
has been fixed it's been fixed for a few
months now but it hasn't been released
it's going to be released sometime this
week
uh but then still the issue is that it's
been in the code base for years
there's still quite a lot of sparks
point 2.x code which uh exhibits this
problem
and unless we all upgrade to the to the
newest version
this is not going to go away
my third example is about my favorite
data data format
and that csvs did they the previous
examples were about css as well but
they were not the stars so this is uh
this is going to be a bit more uh
about the the format itself so when we
think about csv we think
think of a very simple format we think
of it as like
okay so it's a bunch of values and
they're separated by commas and the
rows are separated by new lines and
that's about it um
let's put that definition to a test
because i've seen this definition
and well spoken out loud probably not
written out
but uh let's put it to a test so i'm
gonna use the csc package from python
and to write three rows to a file so a
header
and then a name with with a selenic name
and an age again a name and an h so
there's
two columns three rows or two rows with
data and a and a header
and i'm going to ask pandas to read the
csv and give me the average age which is
56 plus 44 divided by 2
50 sounds about right if we ask spark
the same question
we're going to get and i'm just telling
it as a header and for the schema
everything is standard i'm going to get
44 which
is which is odd because there's just two
data points and it's quite hard to make
a 44 out of
uh these two data points so let's look
at the
let's look at the data frame uh before
we get to data frame i'm
one of my specialties apart from data
engineering is adding and removing
slides minutes before my presentation so
if i'm going to get stumped like i did
just now it's because i have recently
added this
slide so csvs don't have a standard per
se
but there's a professor commons 4180
uh which was published a while ago and
this is the closest to a standard that
we have
and it defines apart from the commas and
the new lines two more rules
that parsers should adhere to and this
is
this sort of reflects uh one of these
rules
uh the rule is that if you have a
uh if you have a quote within your field
which you can't have
you need to escape it just like we need
to escape it in python in a string
the issue is that in csvs in order to
escape it you have to put another quote
in front of it not a backslash
sadly spark by default will quote will
escape
quotes by using backslashes both when
reading and writing data so if you
read some compliant data and write it
out you might
you might mess up your data quite badly
so here we can see that
there was an analyst comma and because
they misunder
misinterpreted these these quotes it
thought that the comma was actually
separating the fields
and it just sort of overflowed some
garbage into the h column
and the 56 get completely lost and
uh and again this is something that bit
us in production systems where we
just relied on the defaults and we gave
it completely standard compliance csvs
and
we we we lost these uh columns of data
without actually uh
without actually noticing it so this is
why we get the 44 as the average because
it's only
computing it from the from the one value
and sort of disregarding this whole
string here
okay now my favorite example this is the
one from the
uh from the talk description uh let's
this is this bit more contrived but but
it is there to prove a point
um let's say you have
uh some pizza orders so there's john
jane and wendy or in pizzas at some
at some dates and they order three five
and one
pizza respectively and if we ask what
is the number of pizzas that they order
in total
we're gonna get uh well nine which
kind of makes sense because we've got
three plus five plus one
equal to nine
um and this is where we encounter
something that's
the quite the opposite of uh losing data
and it's actually
gaining data because if we ask spark the
same question in this data set
i'm i'm also using the mode fail fast
which is not the default which is
basically saying
if you encounter something fishy just uh
raise an exception and and and
and fail um if we ask you how many
pieces got order we get 127
453 whereas in pandas we had
nine if you ask google sheets or excel
or any other
well probably almost any other
processing system we would get nine
but here we have 227 000 which if you
run
some sort of a bi reporting kind of
system
this becomes quite an issue because
there's a small discrepancy between what
you actually have
in your data and what's what this
tool is reporting you so let's look at
the data that we get so this is just
a a printed version of the data frame
that gave us the 127
000 and we can see that apart from these
three rows that
uh that you saw on the original slide
there's a
whole bunch of rows that we didn't see
uh
originally including these hundred
hundred thousand pieces here 123 here
and uh and that's a weird quote here
this brings us to the second rule in
rsc 4180 which is basic which is saying
that
uh so the first one was if you want to
use quotes you can but you need to
escape them
by another quote and the second one is
if you want to use new lines and you
totally can you need to quote
your field so this
is not as commonly known as i'd like it
to be but you can actually have new
lines in your fields like if you want if
you go to excel
and i forget what the what the shortcut
is on uh
well any of the platforms i think it's
like alt enter or control enter you can
actually
add new lines to your fields you can
have a whole poem in your field
and it will it can get exported in a csv
into a single field
and it's going to have new lines in the
in the exported material
in the exported file so
[Music]
how we actually got to this was that we
had some sort of a data set from a crm
or from salesforce
or some other system that had one field
one column which is basically like a
note
or a comment or something like that
where people could write like free form
text
and somebody wrote like a bunch of notes
with new lines and everything which is
completely fine it got exported to csv
just fine
um but
then we started we sort of counted the
rows that we got just to check
that we got the same same number of rows
that we exported from the system
and we had a lot more data that we got
from
the spark pipeline that we got from the
source systems and we sort of dug around
and we found out that
by default spark doesn't really adhere
to this new line rule in
in csvs and just parses csv's row by
row and so disregards that they can sort
of flow
uh flow like this uh you have to tell it
like forcefully you have to tell it like
please
interpret csvs uh and their fields as
possibly multi-line values
so i i thought i'd play with spark i
didn't think this would work and i
so i just played with it and i created
this data set where i had a note where
people just add a note to their order
and i added some legitimate note and
then i just added
a whole bunch of rows that look like the
data that we have and it conformed to
this
to the schema but they're just on new
new lines and i just ended up with a
quote so this is a completely valid csv
if you use pandas excel google sheets
it's gonna work just fine it's gonna
give you nine orders
but if you load it with spark you're
just gonna get a whole lot of
well not garbage because these are
actually interpreted as valid data and
can be acted upon
so uh this is really dangerous
and the and the dangerous part is that
we're using
uh some of the most cutting-edge
technology for data processing and it's
defaults
i'm not saying that the tool cannot read
this file there's there's ways you can
make it
to read it file by adjusting the
settings but by default it cannot read
the data and
actually can cause harm and it can
actually either lose data or add data
or and other things and we're also using
the most common data input format i
don't quote me on that but if you've
worked with
data engineering and and even data
science
you see that as much as we have advances
in part a or c and other binary format
csv are still omnipresent for
um for data exchange
because it's so well it seems to be so
simple for
uh to describe the data
and this is not just these csv's dates
just for the uh for the sake of
uh for the sake of time i've only
described these two but if you look at
the article
i i talk about quite a few more examples
uh there here are just some uh
semi-famous examples from other fields
which
also lead to loss loss of data not in
the traditional sense of losing tables
but
in a sense that it can misinterpret it
so things like the norway problem so if
you have a yaml file and you put in no
as in the iso a shortcut of the iso name
of norway
then it's going to be interpreted as
false rather than the node that you
intended there were some talks about the
defaults in second learn's
logistic regression that would that
would
in some way affect the results
if you work with distributed systems uh
either as a user as a developer you
should be very worried about your data
because there's
a million ways you can lose data in
these
and some of these systems that uh
try to synchronize data between nodes or
between multiple systems
on potentially multiple machines they're
actually designed to lose data it sort
of
sounds weird but it's sort of it's sort
of like how to how to reconcile that if
there if there's a conflict and some
they're like okay look i'm going to
throw away some of the data because this
looks more recent
and i talked about csvs but parsing json
is so much more difficult because this
uh there's a lot more rules and
uh there's a great article as again
linked in my
in my blog post where they talk about
uh different ways to stump various
parses and there's like no two parsers
are alike in terms of like how
what sort of data they allow uh to go
through
so what do we do now so there's uh
there's a few remedies
so uh i think the top one for me is
at the bottom which is basically you
need to be sort of more acquisitive you
have to be
sort of more interested in the tools
that you're using especially if they're
sort of high-level abstractions is one
of the selling points of things like
pandas and spark
and databases is that it sort of gives
you a lot of power
where by just using some very sort of
easy to use uh
language be it a programming language
script language and
and they do a lot of things for you so
if you do pandas don't read csv
it might do uh you might do
decompression my dad will stuff off the
internet in my
in for date types it might do all sorts
of things
but you have to sort of realize this is
not
uh this is not very explicit this is
this is all sort of done automatically
and it might change from version to
version
it might change by getting some sort of
a new data format uh
your way and might be misinterpreted in
ways that you didn't expect
and you can only sort of uh
get around this by either not using
these high level tools which is sort of
quite a waste of time in most cases you
know well then they're not using part
or you might just yeah i have to invest
a lot of time in understanding these
tools and
how they work and i
i covered very basic sort of read csv
group by
some stuff like that but these tools can
do a lot more
uh the same thing you can do is you you
might just be very defensive in your
coding so
uh there are a few options for example
in spark that you can set to
be more cautious about the inputs it's
not going to sort of save you but
in all cases but it's going to save you
in many of these cases
and you want to be using latest versions
of these tools because there are bug
fixes
that get distributed every day
and as i said spark version 3 is a major
it's a major version release that's been
released after years of sparks ii
and it uh fixes a whole lot of date
issues there's actually even time
overflows that i didn't talk about
um i tried to make them sort of change
the csv defaults to
actually use the multi-line approach and
the correct escaping by default
it's been in the uh issue tracker for
about two years now and i was like
please put it in spark 3.0 it's going to
be breaking anyway so
might just break it for the better but i
sadly wasn't listened to
and the last remedy is just taking a
different approach to
the way that you handle invalid data
this is more from from a developer
perspective rather than a user
perspective
so this is a quote from a from jira from
uh from one of the issues where they
basically say
uh where somebody said oh i've got a
obviously invalid data and you parse it
just fine
what uh what's going on they were like
yeah we we
we'd rather return now and just let the
program flow rather than
uh raise exceptions exceptions are for
things that are sort of statically
incorrect so
you're using a function for uh for
for use that cannot be used for stuff
like that
uh that's it for me if i've got more
time i have some
i have some other material but if
there's q a and
we're short on time then i can stop
right now it depends on
further there's one question um
which is whether you could suggest some
best practices from
data reconciliation between source and
destination data
and if there's open source projects
about data quality that are usable or
maybe contribute
um so there is a
there's a few tools they
so on a on a row by row basis we've been
quite uh happy users of json schema
it's sort of more for apis than for json
data but it sort of lets you set
boundaries in terms of like min and max
values regular expressions
and telephone formats email form and
stuff like that but it doesn't really
give you the bigger picture like i want
this data to be on average
uh this uh this value stuff like that
this is what great expectation is very
good for this
was introduced at the workshop today i
i use great expression a little bit it
moves very fast so
your code might break if you write if
you write it and then
sort of upgrade the uh the library so
it's it's a very sort of live system
it does a whole lot of things and i
understand about maybe five percent of
the tool
but for things like i want this to be
not now
95 of the time and the rest of the time
i want the median value to be
in this range and these sorts of things
is very useful
yeah and uh then there's some
specialized tools like dqdeq
which is specialized for spark that's by
aws aws
from amazon so there's a few tools i
i'm not super happy about uh either of
them those sort of
different uses um and uh
what i like most is things like do i
have some sort of a
ground truth in terms of like a sum of
a crucial column or a
some sort of property like this has to
be distinct or these cannot be no
and just have these sort of queries that
will sort of run through my data on a
daily basis
or at ingest time and it will tell me
hey this is not what i expected so this
is this is sort of more manual than
things like great expectations or dq but
it's sort of
instead of very well debuggable and it's
very very well implementable that's
where
uh so yeah so that's my uh thanks
and another question by vincent which is
uh what's the funniest story about
data laws that you know of
um i'm not sure if it's funny or sad
but it's basically
well things like data
like like severe data loss and pipeline
problems stuff like that
and we weren't told for months like that
there was an issue like there was there
was a pipeline they were building for
an internal customer they were like yeah
please do it by last week
and uh we deployed it and then it was
just like spilling garbage all over the
system
and we didn't really well it sounds bad
if i say we didn't care but it was it
was not it was not a high priority issue
for us
and uh and nobody really cared and
that's how we found out that the
pipeline is
is needless it doesn't really have to be
there if nobody really really
sort of cares enough to understand that
the data is wrong it's not that they
didn't go there it's just they didn't
understand that it was wrong
and uh so that's where there's needs to
be more communication it was
it was a problem one of both parts uh
they should have
we should have been more upfront about
what it is and
how we can deliver the data they should
be more upfront about the use cases
and how higher quality they need and and
stuff like that so
yeah not noticing a data loss for
extended periods of time is the sort of
the fun side sad story yeah
um one last question i think um what's
your
what's your opinion on building an ml
based data profiling tool for
data quality purposes or have you come
across any
um so
i'm not i'm not really big on ml in
general so this is going to be a bit
biased
but the what i perceive to be the
problem is that
there's always people with expertise who
know what the data should look like i'm
not saying that if you've got 300
columns you're going to know about all
of them
but there are some inherent qualities
you know that the
price with v8 should be greater or equal
to the price without v80 and stuff like
that
and there should be some sort of range
you can absolutely build
i would i would advocate for simpler
models because they could they will be
better explainable
you can build some models to sort of
uh catch some relationships between your
variables
but for the most part i've been quite
happy using
rule-based systems because they're
easier to build they're easier to code
up they're easier to version
and uh the faster stuff like that so
go for it i'll be happy to
be told that there are systems like that
that exist or that work well
and i'll be happy to use them if
they're out there cool thanks